KUMAIL NANJIANI
We are from the cast of...
GEMMA CHAN
And here's everything you need to know
about our film...
DON LEE
...in 60 seconds.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
[Inhales]
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Boom.
BARRY KEOGHAN
Big bang.
SALMA HAYEK
The universe comes into existence.
RICHARD MADDEN
Powerful beings known as the Celestials
roam the universe.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
I think the Infinity Stones show up.
Maybe? I don't know!
KINGO
That explains so much.
LIA MCHUGH
A power Celestial creates the Eternals.
SALMA HAYEK
That's us!
KARUN
The original superheroes.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
5000 B.C.
BARRY KEOGHAN
Suddenly, the Deviants emerge
to destroy all life in existence.
LAUREN RIDLOFF [in sign language]
Really scary.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
They are literally the worst.
SALMA HAYEK
And the Eternals are sent to Earth
aboard a giant
spaceship named the Domo.
GEMMA CHAN
And save humanity from extinction.
ANGELINA JOLIE
Fast forward hundreds of years...
GEMMA CHAN
The Eternals eliminate the
last two Deviants
and decide to break up.
LAUREN RIDLOFF [in sign language]
Bummer!
SALMA HAYEK
Gilgamesh learns a delicious pie recipe.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Sersi starts dating Dane Whitman.
DANE WHITMAN
I'm Dane.
ANGELINA JOLIE
Thanos destroys half of all life
in the universe.
LIA MCHUGH
Super annoying!
GEMMA CHAN
But the Avengers save the day
and bring everyone back.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Yay.
SALMA HAYEK
Out of nowhere, these annoying Deviants...
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
...return with a vengeance.
DON LEE
Now the Eternals must reunite
to protect humanity once again.
[Ding]
AJAK
It is time.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Woo!
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Phew! Did we do it?
SALMA HAYEK
Did we?
ANGELINA JOLIE
We done?
GEMMA CHAN
I think we did it.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Don't miss Eternals. It’s here. In 10 Days.